the Trump war on the media and a Free
Press continues and the theme is this
phrase the enemy of the people the enemy
of the people is the phrase that keeps
coming up about the press by Donald
Trump and by his cronies and Sarah
Huckabee Sanders the White House press
secretary was asked directly a number of
times during a press briefing late last
week as the weekend was kicking off is
the press the enemy of the people as far
as she is concerned and or as far as the
Trump administration is concerned she
was asked this by the press at a press
briefing and one of the ways this is
being written up is Sarah Huckabee
Sanders refuses to deny that the press
is the enemy of the American people what
you have to understand and I'm gonna
play a clip for you here is that when
she said time and again I'm here to
represent the president's views and the
president has made his views clear it's
more than a non-denial that they see the
press as the enemy of the American
people
it is the acknowledgment that they see
the press as the enemy of the American
people she refused to say no multiple
times and said the Trump Trump is
already spoken about this it's a
slightly longer clip I'm going to play
for you because I want you to pay
attention to the dynamics of how there
are multiple opportunities for her to
just say no no big picture I or the
Trump administration whoever she's
speaking for at the time don't see the
press as the enemy of the American
people she doesn't do that she does
believe and she is restating that the
Trump administration does believe that
the press is the enemy of the American
people let's take a look Jim on Sarah's
question from NPR she asked you about
Ivanka Trump's statement that the press
is not the enemy of the people and she
asked you whether or not the press is
the enemy of the people you read off a
laundry list of your concerns about the
press and things that you feel like
afford it but you did not say that the
press is not the enemy of the people and
I I think it would be a good thing if
you were to say right here at this
briefing that the press the people who
are gathered in this room right now
right doing their jobs every day asking
questions of officials like the ones you
brought forward earlier or not the enemy
of the people I I think we deserve that
the president has made his position
known I also think it's ironic I'm
trying to answer your question I
politely waited and I even called on you
despite the fact that you interrupted me
why calling on your colleague I said
it's ironic and which is why I
interrupted I'm trying if you if you
finish if you would not mind letting me
have a follow-up that would be fun but
it's ironic Jim that not only you and
the media attacked the president for his
rhetoric when they frequently lower the
level of conversation in this country
repeatedly repeatedly the media resorts
to personal attacks without any content
other than to incite anger the media has
attacked me personally on a number of
occasions including your own Network
said I should be harassed as a life
sentence that I should be choked ice
officials are not welcomed in their
place of worship and personal
information is shared on the Internet
when I was hosted by the Correspondents
Association of which almost all of you
are members of you brought a comedian
out to attack my appearance and call me
a traitor to my own gender in fact as I
know I'm as far as I know I'm the first
press secretary in the history of the
United States that's required Secret
Service protection the media continues
to ratchet up the verbal assault against
the president and everyone in this
administration and certainly we have a
role to play but the media has a role to
play for the discourse in this country
as well if I may follow up excuse me you
did not say in the course of those
remarks that you just made that the
press is not the enemy of the people are
we to take it from what you just said we
all get put through the wringer we all
get put in the meat grinder in this town
and you're no exception and I'm sorry
that that happened to you I wish that
that had not
but for the sake of this this room the
people who are in this room this
democracy this country all the people
around the world are watching what
you're saying Sarah and the White House
for the United States of America the
presidency should not refer to us as the
enemy of the people his own daughter
acknowledges that and all I'm asking you
to do Sarah is to acknowledge that right
now and right here
I appreciate your passion I share it
I've addressed this question I've
addressed my personal feelings I'm here
to speak on behalf of the president he's
made his comments clear so Sarah was
that a yes or no one presses the enemy
of the American people she talks about
how she hasn't liked reports about her
and satires of her but that's not the
question the question is about the role
and the perception of the media by this
administration and if you're a defender
of the Constitution if you believe in
checks and balances the answer to this
question should be and it really has to
be a completely unequivocal and
definitive no of course the press is not
the enemy of the American people
this wasn't a vague question open to
interpretation it's Jim Acosta from CNN
who asked the question here he was
specific she still filibustered didn't
answer and in fact she's saying yes the
press is the enemy I speak for the
president she said that's what Trump has
said and that's what the position of the
administration appears to be and
bringing up satirical pieces done about
her I guess it's either to distract her
to try to get some sympathy she might be
a more sympathetic character if she
stopped telling depraved and horrific
lies to the American people day in and
day out but it continues to amaze me how
the party that claims to be against the
safe spaces and the trigger warnings is
regularly and so easily triggered and
what's dangerous and vile about this
position is that it is even worse than
what we've seen from some of the worst
Republicans I don't romanticize Bush you
know that rap but even Bush would say
directly when he had big conflicts with
individual media outlets a free press is
necessary and healthy to democracy it's
such a simple thing to say if you
believe in it and they're just not
saying it because they don't believe in
it we also know that Sarah Huckabee
Sanders calling card is off you ski
Chintu yeah so she could have walked
that tightrope and done it a little bit
better right between appeasing President
Trump and also reassuring the importance
of a free press like she could have said
that most outlets are totally fine but
there are some liberal reporters out
there doing a horrible job and named
them for example like she could have
young both things she could have played
both sides there like she normally does
she decided not to go with I don't know
if calling out specific reporters would
be walking the tightrope necessarily but
the big picture is creeping
authoritarianism and when it's all said
and done either in 2020 or in 2024 I
hope that Sarah Huckabee Sanders is
remembered for what she's become which
is one of the most disgusting
participants in this aberrant
administration and aberrant not on
policy but in terms of it's just
fundamental and basic disrespect for the
base tenets of the foundation of the
United States of America send me your
thoughts if you're as concerned as I am
about the battle against the press I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman and the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show today's
program is made possible in part by Indo
Chino which makes custom suits and
shirts the reality is I see a lot of
really bad suits and I was just at a
wedding actually and most of the suits
looked horrible and the truth is that
generic off-the-rack suits just aren't
going to look as good as a personalised
suit especially one made at indogene oh
you can order online or go into one of
their showrooms here in Boston they have
a showroom I went in I worked with Chris
we took all sorts of measurements
measurements I didn't even know you
could take on a human body but what it
led to was a custom really great fitting
suit you can choose your fabric you can
personalize the lapel the jacket lining
the monogram whatever you want really
even the buttons you place your order
wait for it to arrive in three weeks or
less and you're gonna have a
great-looking suit you can shop online
at endo Chino dot-com as I mentioned
showrooms all over North America and
this week my listeners and viewers can
get any premium Indo Chino suit for just
three hundred and seventy nine bucks at
Indo Chino comm when you enter the code
Pakman at checkout that is over 50% off
the regular price for a premium
made-to-measure suit stop looking like a
goof at weddings and funerals I mean
that's the sad reality as well you got
to have a good suit or two for important
life events shipping is free again
that's endo Chino dot-com promo code PA
que ma n to get any premium suit for 379
bucks plus free shipping great deal for
a perfectly tailored suit